In general, we like the ratio between texels and pixels to be around one to
one. If the texels cover too many pixels, we'll get blurring as we saw in the
previous lesson. This isn't so bad for real textures, so erring a bit on the
side of smaller textures is not the worst crime that you can commit. If a pixel
covers too many texels, we get minification which leads to different problems.
For a high resolution checker texture, it simply causes the edges to become
sharp. However, the problem is much worse than this under normal viewing
conditions. Changing the texture resolution does not help. When a pixel covers
more than one texel, minification occurs. This is what's happening in the
distance. There's a separate filter on the texture for this situation. The
reason it's separate is that this problem has a different solution. Currently,
this minification filter is set to be nearest neighbor. As we saw for
magnification, this is usually a bad choice. Let's turn on bilinear
interpolation for the minification filter, too. This helps a little bit towards
the middle of the image, but not much. The problem is that each pixel in the
distance covers a few texels. As we get closer and closer to the horizon, the
number of texels per pixel increases. When the fragment shader looks up what's
in the texture, it gets whatever texel happens to be at the center of the
pixel. At the horizon, this selection is almost random, so we get noise as we
vary between white and black texels. Even with bilinear interpolation on, it's
still just noise. With magnification we found that too many pixels covering one
texel caused blurring. Getting this ratio closer to one to one made things just
right. Here we have too many texels in one pixel. One solution is to go in the
opposite direction than we went for magnification. Instead of making our
checkerboard have a larger and larger resolution, we'd like it if the distant
pixels used a lower resolution texture. This would bring the ratio of texels to
pixels about back to one to one. I can show this by lowering the resolution of
the texture. I'll say it again, the video may not show much difference as these
videos are heavily compressed so that they're quicker to download. Your best
bet is to try this demo out for yourself. It follows this lesson. Anyway,
changing the resolution helps a bit towards the middle of the image, since
these pixels have more and more texels as we move to the horizon. Blurriness is
much better than noisiness, especially when moving the view around. Things
still look terrible on the horizon because every pixel in that area covers so
many texels that even our two by two texel image fails. If we go to a one by
one checkerboard pattern, that might help a bit. What in the world is a one by
one checker board? Well, its just a single checker square, a single texel.
Since I can't put both black and white in this texel, I make this texel grey.
Choosing this texture is like the nuclear option, the horizon looks better than
noise but now everything is grey. To sum up, at some point near the horizon,
there are just too many texels to pixels. So to avoid noise we go to grey. Try
the demo yourself at this point and see how changing the texel to pixel ratio
affects the image.